Mattress girl some feminists to this day
they still were just telling the truth
there were text messages Facebook
messages from mattress girls showing
that it was alive which of the most
famous which is the famous rape hoaxes
would you say sticks out in your mind is
the most egregious we want to get into
this here today after Kavanagh because
the same thing comes the same phrase
comes up all the time there's a rape
accusation right what do we always hear
we are well I would a little lie you
know we need to believe it's just
another way of saying it believe
survivors it's why would you sort of lie
why would a little lie about rape why
would she okay you know why because
people lie that's it lie and it will
show you people lie for all kinds of
reasons sometimes for personal gain for
Fame notoriety flow game to harm an
enemy to get on the cover of magazine I
have known people some people have grown
tits to get on the covers of magazines
people lie all the time
that's not an argument the first day of
cabin on remember right before this
happened to all the time they were
threatening if he was confirmed some
threatened social media blackouts I
don't know the rest of us we're just I
mean they we don't care please move it's
depression
we shouldn't going on that wall earlier
than all right
top five rape hoaxes that I would listen
I would love to see yours comment below
number five is six out in my mind is the
Rolling Stone UVA scandal remember this
one where they wrote in Rolling Stone
they wrote an article about the supposed
a gang rape at university Virginia and
it didn't happen
guys hear about this story I remember
what's his name right yeah yeah Eddie
Helms was speaking at their did it
commenced yeah and he had to mention it
at because it was so awkward at that
point Rolling Stone actually was forced
to issue a complete retraction but don't
take my word for it
Rolling Stones managing editor published
a note today about discrepancies in the
victims story he wrote quote we have
come to the conclusion that our trust in
her was misplaced by discrepancy east by
the me they mean lies
I mean outright lies discrepancies I
hope he'd lost his job right work in the
foodie section somewhere they said he
just they just had confirmation bias and
that was their problem yeah the
confirmation story obviously and you
look at everything the support lesson
else who among us doesn't have a bias
and it hasn't entirely destroyed a man's
life was entirely fabricated false rape
activity what happens number four this
is one I don't even know what to call it
but it was really big that the Texas
teen gang rape this is no sorry number
four did I say number one no no it was a
their name was I think it was a Breanna
Talbott but yeah yeah she remember she
broke into a church body bloodied
screamed at three black men had raped
her so you know right away did you think
the medical team found not only no
evidence of sexual assault they also
found problems of the story and then the
team confessed that she had entirely
made it all up the wounds were
self-inflicted that's why I think this
is one of the most this is one of the
worst offenses because she took time to
hurt herself and burst into a church Wow
which means again there's got to be one
you Neve talked about how victim culture
will go why would they live why would
anyone want to be black in America why
would anyone want to be a victim of
sexual assault
I'm not saying anyone actually wants to
be the physical victim of sexual assault
threat why would someone want to claim
that publicly well I asked this person
why they would go through the effort of
physically harming themselves because
they thought they would get such a leg
up by accusing three random black men of
rape there is something to be said for
it even if it's just a crazy person who
wants notoriety yeah so why would she
lie she likes it rough you looking
forward to exile she just punched
herself with it so she knew cheap xiexie
Dempster ID no no no no none her died
because she is you know she did just
things that she would yeah so you know
she probably liked scraped your knees
with some sandpaper
it's a notification bail after subscribe
to the channel on YouTube because
apparently that doesn't mean anything
anymore so notification bill and join
Michael of course get the daily show
every single day not for free show
number three the Duke Lacrosse hope oh
my gosh this is the word you me get away
from these it really is I guess it's
just a bit like late Clarence Thomas
notice it's a modern day lynching
through public opinion yeah
and the people doing it they're rich
white liberals yeah let's more just
let's put the team right College Dean
yeah crossing the hardest Ripper for a
party I think yeah lacrosse players yeah
it was a pretty much all white team
lacrosse team they were ranked number
one in the nation their season was
canceled and all of this - yes
Carolina's Attorney General will dismiss
all charges against the three young men
well that seems pretty cut and dry yeah
yeah yeah this was like let me know this
you know because you don't follow up on
these stories the the hoaxer was later
convicted of stabbing her boyfriend to
death
you thought you got away from the
stereotype for a second man oh right
back into it you know what they say
hindsight is Twenty not rape number two
mattress girl violate some feminists to
this day they still were just telling
the truth about your rape yes no what's
the story that the Pumpkinhead who still
carries his Lantern around crane is that
what it was a head of Sleepy Hollow
headless horse mr. headless horseman I
don't know what the legend the point is
they still think she's lugging her
mattress around to this day as a victim
of rape we have there were text messages
Facebook messages from mattress girl
showing that it was alive she began
carrying this mattress around as an art
project and putting his name attached to
the whole story first time and time
again it garnered worldwide attention
got her a ton of she was on the cover of
New York Times Magazine Nungesser says
that she ruined his name and his rep
variable Robin that's right to an
education Columbia now agrees with him
and in a reverse title 9 decision they
have offered him a settlement why would
she lie right this girl that you didn't
quite beat herself up liar liar stone
going to a church
she just loved a mattress around campus
for an entire semester by the way go
read the texts they're graphic it's
they're worse than penthouse letters the
dedication you've ever read any of those
yes she wanted it up yeah it was it was
it was well and actually there's a lot
of if you read the text it seems like
she was mad that he wasn't in her I was
like yeah this is getting pretty crazy
Holly does anyone know this I've talked
we've had people on the show thing was
mark Duplass in a Michael Ian Black
where they met and like no yeah no idea
mattress go Mike no mattress goes Ally
but are you sure about that are you sure
yes yes but they're doing the same thing
with Kavanagh now do you realize five
years from now we'll be talking about
dr. Christine Ford don't matter well
still be toppled like hey remember that
just like Clarence Thomas yeah this
mattress girl was really think about
this stuff the guy's never gonna get his
name back no you know the first thing
that guy's gonna apply for a job they're
gonna run a search the first thing pop
up is not going to be Oh declared
innocent it's going to be this girl
carried a mattress around with your name
at Columbia for a year because you raped
her you're not gonna call back yeah no
it's going to change your name at that
point yeah it's on you just go to the
judge too much credit she wasn't that
committed she wasn't cut you know you
want us to believe you
Carrie Asura number one the worst hoax
to me and you may not have heard of this
is Emmett Till we have a clip more than
60 years ago Emmett Till was abducted
and murdered by two men after a woman
claimed that Emmett Till who is 14 years
old
whistled at her and grabbed terrible
Brown's mother held an open casket
funeral to show the world the brutality
of her son's killing the two men were
acquitted but later confessed to killing
Till and in a book published last year
by Tim Tyson the woman at the center of
that case Carolyn Bryant Dhanam admitted
she exaggerated part of her testimony
first off this is why I hate cable news
because he has to read that story yeah
and in a published a real story this
one's not even a rape it was just an
accusation of whistling whistling yeah
whistling with intent though whistling
with intent it's actually really
important to note by the way
it was Trump CEO day we open the Emmett
Till case yes yeah justice for them the
guy who hates black guys right yeah
the guy who hates black is the one he
was with justice for Trayvon justice for
was it to me or rice okay justice for
Mike Brown hands up don't you actually
it was a more like punching a cop in the
face reaching your ears on the cop shot
but here you actually have somebody's
completely innocent who was accused by a
lynch mob of whistling Trump really not
a peep what about justice ribbit till
yeah yeah yeah man what Obama said about
Trayvon yeah if I had a son he would
look like Trayvon
that's because he'd be a dad if I had a
son he'd be me are you if I had a son
you you can bet your ass you'd be making
purple drank along with everyone else
that's what he was doing what you gonna
do for Trayvon by the bonus rape hoax
the Julie sweat Nick the gang rape three
ladies came out right I think there was
there was one with no name right was the
lady with no name is after Christine
Ford and yes Deborah Ramirez it was
Christine for Deborah Mears it's just so
hard to keep straight I was like Oh
[Laughter]
health care oh Jesus well you know it's
good for you guys because we'll be
paying for your sickle cell creepy poor
lawyer Michael I'm and he pushed the
Julie sweat Nick narrative for who
accused Cavanaugh of I don't know like
gang rape parties the allegations from
Julie sweat Nick who alleged in a signed
affidavit she attended well over ten
parties she saw judge Brett Kavanaugh
then in high school
drink excessively at many of these
parties and engage in abusive and
physically aggressive behavior towards
girls first off a couple of things now
it makes sense they say a drank so much
you guys had you don't really drink that
often
that's why Cory Booker was asking
Cavanaugh do
drink on weekdays because like to maybe
do a black person that's like whoa he's
a drum house yeah Fred testimony I think
Captain oats an alpha male why would you
keep going if everybody this came out
and if you look there was a sweat nick
story right she came forward and she
said I can't believe it I was described
when I was brave and I said four and and
now actually the claims were so
outlandish because I wanted to focus on
Ford but this was treated entirely
legitimately either way let me talk
about it the news was released at 7:00
everyone ran with it and then it was
dead before lawrence O'Donnell could
broadcast his menstrual cramps like it
was that it was that quick but now the
left is accusing a vanetti of being a
plant from Donald Trump to try and
discredit the real accusers of Kavanagh
we don't want it to be lumped in with
the one who said gang rape train
Trump put him there to make us seem like
we lie that's a deep conspiracy really
deep conspiracy that goes deep I mean
you have to believe Trump is brilliant
you have to believe Trump is so
brilliant that you know he'd be so smart
that he could hire someone as stupid as
a vanetti trust him to carry the lie
someone just said the other day you
don't know what it's like as a woman
right now to be scared you know what men
are terrified right now especially me
[Laughter]
that's going straight to Eric the true
just think about this women listen no
one wants you to be raped Jimmy do you
have any idea how terrible a crime
rapist rapist get raped in prison
ironically on principle yeah because
they're hate child molesters and rapists
do not fare well in prison amongst
criminals they're hated because we're
considered a bad crime no one likes rape
even the arsonists
okay the serial killers think that
rapists are beneath them no one likes
rape that being said it is terrifying to
be a man today because guess what when
people said why would a woman ever lie
because people lie women lie about their
way to all the time women lie about me
whether they've had work done so then
there's a there's a there's a ton of
reasons for like let's say they're
kidding right now these women coming
full with rape like Julie sweat Nick so
the caterer figured out you got a cookie
by lying you know
did you already have a cookie today
after you cleaned your room no here's
another one red all right I guess you
better take all the cookies jeez he's
had a rough childhood kid that's what
happens people live because if something
to gain from a lie again but listen
alright it doesn't really matter usually
to get some free crap that's what it is
90% of women's faces are lies take that
make up a quarter hell are you this act
like a deep wound that you need to get
out a little bit right have you been oh
I thought you hung yourself the worst
the worst part about we want to believe
you we really you just said it right
dude universally it's bad we want to
believe you can you please just give us
some proof that's all we're asking and
this is the thing Liars think about kids
right you guys have kids the worst part
is an enabler of lies that's the real
problem and parents sometimes are crazy
just don't if your parents asked if you
we gave you so many so we just say no
and so then what you have here is like
you have you have a woman who comes
forward and potentially lies I don't
know about glue I don't know about about
what's-her-name for allegedly but you
have this lie from a woman and then you
have a lie from a Mike 11 Eddy here I
don't know Gloria Allred whatever so
you've got two lies then you have a
political ally like Feinstein who jumps
on board now there are three lies so
you've got this this sort of
amalgamation it's this it's all of these
different lies into a super lie it's
like when the Power Rangers became the
Megazord only with lies it's the
Megazord of locks the point is I don't
even know that the place it is is the
lying from all sides of the political
spectrum and or the gender binary so
political spectrum gender binary there
you go
comment away I want to see that bees
nest right now it's been going on since
the dawn of mankind and the problem that
everyone has hear people talk about how
we're divided and I've seen even some
people on the right go well maybe at
this point there be some time for
healing do you think you would want any
healing do you think you would want to
unite with someone who falsely accused
you of rape just like I don't expect the
woman to want to hold hands and sing we
are the world with a guy who read a
trade honor
that's a guy who was accused of running
a trade on a woman is going to want to
unite with her
that's silly instead of talking about
unity instead of talking about finding
common ground on this let's talk about
the truth
and it happens every few months it
happens every year or so and then what
just happens when the truth comes out we
forget about it we just go out Duke
Lacrosse another friends out now she
stabbed her boyfriend we know and we've
moved on from that story it's going to
the same thing with Brett Kavanaugh why
because it's as simple as this people
lie
our entire legal system is bet it's
predicated on this idea that human
beings lie and we have to safeguard
against it and we want to throw that
away why for Gloria Allred know people
like looting you hey there youtube
viewer if you like this video watch one
of my other videos
oh it's playing in one of those boxes
I'd say subscribe or hit the
notification build but I don't really
know what that means in today's day and
age on YouTube but if you join it loud
or with credit comm slash mug club you
won't only see clips you'll get to watch
the full daily one-hour show every
single day and support our content
making sure that we can still get clips
up here on YouTube for the freeloaders
who can't afford it and or are just
cheap pricks